oh
my God
Islam net is raising funds to establish
a Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support
every person who prays there every kid
that learns about Islam every youngster
that memorized the Quran all of this and
so much more can be on your scale of
Good Deeds click the link and donate
what you can and share the video for
even extra reward came across of two
non-muslims who are in Masjid nabawi
interestingly we don't know how they got
there but they tried to enter the mosque
of the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him they were stopped and this is what
happened let's just watch the video for
ourselves and we'll come back
foreign
[Laughter]
now at this very instance we could act
in two ways one can be
how dare you what are you doing here do
you not have no shame you have no hijab
look how you're dressed wearing jeans
whatever it may be and you're here
trying to come to the promise message
what kind of impression do you think
that would have left with them about
Islam how do you think they would have
think and that's why we shouldn't
conflate knowledge with wisdom or
someone who's knowledgeable with a lack
of adapt that's why if you read Imam
bukhari's book he talks deeply about
etiquette and manners it is so
fundamental and key that the prophet
Muhammad peace before him said I came
for nothing but a perfect good character
good character is fundamental so much so
that the prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him said two things that are going to be
heavily their judgment is once tawheed
and good manners this is how important
in its brothers and sisters in Islam but
alhamdulillah Saudi uh the officials in
the ground dealt with them in peace
explained to them what it was and
inshallah it will be a means for them to
come to Islam that is how we should be
when somebody comes to the must be
wearing a tattoo or a woman who walks in
you shouldn't shun them and we have this
not all every older generation but
they'll be like what are you doing get
out of here how have some manners and
treat them well because that thing how
you make them feel they would never
forget it
that's what I wanted to say and we asked
Allah to guide these two individuals we
don't know how they ended up there but
Allah guides maybe it's a means for them
to accept Islam that's what I wanted to
say from sisters till next time may
Allah bless you guys
[Music]
um
foreign
we want to establish an amazing Masjid
for the sake of Allah in the country of
Norway click on the link and donate now
for the sake of Allah